- I broke my neck, I beat
cancer and I'm going to Rio.
This is the first time that women's rugby
will be in the Olympics.
I'm Jillion Potter and I
play rugby for Team USA.
USA
Rugby, in particular, is a very
good life lessons teacher,
so when you get tackled
you have to get back up
no matter how hard it
is, I'm gonna get up.
I broke my neck playing rugby in 2010.
But when I was hit I felt and I heard
just pop, pop, pop, pop, pop,
and I knew immediately
something was wrong.
When the doctors came in and told me
I might not ever be able
to play rugby again,
I like tried to silently cry for awhile.
I went through this like
period of allowing myself
to, to be upset and then being
like get it together Jillion,
like you can be strong in this moment.
There was about a year
between when I broke my neck
and when I was able to
get back on the field
with my team and then in June of 2014,
I was diagnosed with a very
rare soft tissue cancer.
I had chemo and radiation for seven months
and I lost about 20 pounds.
Throughout the treatment I was actually
able to workout and that was something
that I was pretty adamant about.
Thankfully the chemotherapy worked
and I'm cancer-free,
but it could have easily
turned the other way and I don't think
I could even imagine
what that would be like,
but I would hope that I would still
have that attitude of never giving up
and rugby was instrumental
in getting me back
to where I am today.
The rugby community, they really helped me
stay positive and keep working out,
keep that fire to say I'm gonna be back
and I'm gonna be ready for Rio.
(upbeat music)